[Music]  you ran into a fan who had a Tyrion mask  is that right yeah um well listen I  don't remember like a huge amount of  this night it was a it was comic-con Oh  comic-con yeah you know I've been the  guy was hung with you about yeah and and  this fan supposedly came up to me and in  this this tyrion mass yeah and being the  loyal wife that i am you know i just  gave him a quick lick okay take a look  and say look at that photograph right  there  [Laughter]  but what happens is you don't remember  it because you were in a happy state  having a good time you're having a good  time feeling no pain  but then TMZ runs that photo and then  there are a lot of people that thought  oh that's not a guy in a mask  you don't mean they but is that peter  dinklage peter yeah I'm not gonna do  anything to dispel those rumors pizza's  a sexy guy yeah yeah good he has a wife  so I don't think he'd be too pleased  with you and your cue please no  you